oh vfs you look so
fantastic speaking of looking fantastic
our next guest she used to walk runways
all around the world and like us now
she's cooped up at home
juggling work and three kids with some
very creative thinking
oh yeah this photo went totally viral
and
why not come on it's so fun great sense
of humor
everyone it's molly sims
you look gorgeous oh thank you i'm so
glad i could join you guys today
i also noticed that you're rocking a
beautiful pale
color in the waterline of your eyes
which is making them look oh so sparkly
oh so sparkly just a little bit i love
beauty and
makeup and all things that and all
things that are pretty
let me just start by saying look
there are plenty of websites out there
i've poured through so many of them
yours really is so much of a cut above
it is so elevated it's such an amazing
wonderfully
like navigational site
and all those things count yeah we
really wanted to have a place where
women could go and you know
be a mom be a partner be a girlfriend be
a wife but also
the products that she needs it's all
curated it's a one-stop shop
i really do love it i mean we have great
gift guides that are curated we have
real articles i lost my mom
this year and we talk a lot about grief
and we talk about girlfriends and
just really digging just digging a
little bit
um deeper than before this year
has been such a year of loss
and such a year of new experiences
and new coping mechanisms yeah i
never thought you know i never thought
that listen she was definitely sick i
just never thought that i would lose
you know my best friend you know daring
during a pandemic you know but
it's been hard you know but it's also
it's been great because i've had such a
great community reach out to me
and i've had great people to speak to
and it's just
it's definitely you know a process and i
think
sometimes in our business that we only
show like
the filtered instagram like perfect
part and life's just not like that you
know what i mean
sadly more people can relate to your
experience
of going through something so difficult
then they can the fabulousness
and um this year i
actually spent thanksgiving alone and i
hadn't done that
since i was in my 20s and my kids were
with their dad this year
and they just kind of wanted to do their
own thing
but i um it was it was just such a
different holiday and such a different
year for everybody and i
i can't tell you how much that
how appreciated your candor
and being able to share that with people
it's going to touch people so much
because unfortunately again
sadly there are so many people who have
experienced
so much lost this year and when they
look at a
beautiful kind uh woman
like you and they see themselves
and their experiences that's what makes
your website so much more and i must say
molly
that i really think that you should
write a book because
one of my favorite things about your
website is
what a great writer you are you took
a nighttime routine and turned it into
something
that i was so transported to and it just
had this honesty
and this humor i literally i was
like um doing something in my closet i
was probably either eating in my closet
drinking in my closet sleeping in my
closet or hiding in my closet
but it's just you know you have those
moments of like you're literally gonna
have a nervous breakdown and then the
next time you're like oh my god i'm
gonna just
i'm just gonna laugh at like the
craziness of all of it
but yes i love being open i think
sometimes
we do you know cover up the things that
people kind of want to see
and you know my kids sometimes literally
look at me and they're like
we you're you're literally gonna you're
gonna really tape us to the ground i'm
like
we're gonna have so much fun i'm gonna
get
something done for 15 minutes
everybody loved that post i said it
and i was like that is so cool that is
so clever
yeah we're in real life you're in it i'm
in it you know it's like
okay it's like am i ready for 2020 to be
over i have to say
i'm ready for 2020 to be over but it's
it's some good things have come out of
it as well um i was making a joke to my
daughter and i actually put in i have
this
like 2012 um
honda odyssey minivan and i love it
because it has like a big
screen in the back i have a chrysler
pacifica minivan
actually oh my gosh i'm looking into it
because i'm trying to find
a hybrid minivan and it's like the only
one on the market
i love my vinnie van i i'm obsessed with
my minivan
it's awesome also i know this is gonna
sound bad
but i want my children as far away from
me in my car as possible like if i could
i'd drive a stretch limo with the thing
that went up so i put on groundhog's day
for them and none other than andy
mcdowell
do i see on a news program
the next morning and someone's like uh
groundhog's day isn't that crazy and she
said yeah but you know
that movie is actually about living the
same day over and over so that you have
a chance to reevaluate your life so you
can do things
differently and i was like
whoa you know this year has definitely
taught us like you said about
groundhog's day it's like
really you know those days you do get to
have over and over now and
and sometimes that's not all bad you
know molly
um will you come hang out with us right
now for the next segment
i really don't want to say goodbye i
love hanging out with you
you have so much to offer the world and
you have
some beauty and mollysims.com
will you come hang out with me i'd love
to
[Music]
you